all right welcome everyone uh now we
have another talk on um open source uh
developer uh Adin and he's going to walk
us through pickle which is one of the uh
psychic learn libraries and he's also
going to talk about his uh experience
working as an open source
developer uh enjoy the
talk hello um nice to see you now here
we're going to talk about some having a
little bit of fun with pickle
and um how we realized like a long time
ago that there are certain things that
are not ideal what we could do about it
um and what we did or what we have done
so
far um I'm Adin I did my like my
academic life was in bioinformatics
after that I didn't want to work for big
Pharma so I went into machine learning
Consulting left a biosite behind um did
a bunch of stuff then ended up working
on psych learn uh I woke up one day
asking if I want to be a ctive I was
like hell yeah why not um and then since
then i' I've been working on also filin
and um
skops so we're going to talk about
pickle and um things that not you don't
necessarily want to happen but it could
happen when you load pickle files um
let's see I'm going to import
pickle and then I'm going to load this
by string uh probably by looking at the
bite string you can imagine what it
already does is it large enough or do
you want it larger people in the
back bit
larger
okay um when I run this it prints hello
world and it returns
zero um so you can already see there's a
side effect here I just loaded something
it did return zero so like what you
usually do is that you put that in a
variable and you go on with your life
but you would not expect that side
effect and it's not even printing
something it's doing cm. EO um so even
worse um how does it work well this
relies on OS being available when you're
loading pickle um kind of clearly here
it's doing os. system and then
echoing um and then you could be like if
you know pickle well you could be like
well I could actually tackle that could
have my own on picare and then I'm going
to go be like there are certain things
that I allow and then there are certain
things that I don't allow and then I'm
fine well yeah maybe it does fix some
issues
definitely uh but there
is this oh my favorite thing is this one
which exactly says well you wanted to do
that now let's do an exploit uh and you
create a custom pickle that changes the
global variables that you were using in
your U restricted on pickle and then you
can again load whatever you want it's a
really nice read I definitely recommend
you going through this um so this was
the state and then when you look at the
the the pickle documentation in Python
it definitely says do not unpickle data
received from an unrusted or an
authenticated course um people used to
do things like well I do I want to like
have some safe Constructors or safe on
pickling back in the day uh but since
python 2.3 so a long time ago they
removed that they were like no there
actually exploits against those um and
me being in the psych learn World um we
want people to be able to dump their
models and share their models um so how
do we do
that before getting there let's talk a
little bit about some of the machineries
of the
pickle we have the Pickler and then you
have the UNP Pickler so what we did
above here was that we would have an a
custom onpicer with a fine class that we
overwrite there uh and then you have a
bunch of instruction set um of codes um
that are in your pickle file and
basically when you load pickle you're
running code that at the as the result
of running that code some data is
constructed and you get the result of
that which means you're running code so
like not all of that code has to be
exactly for the purpose of constructing
the object that you want to
return how does pickle work how does
pickle know what to how to pickle an
object a python object when you have a
very very simple python object like
imagine you don't have any fancy new
Thunder new defined it's just a like an
init Constructor uh you have a bunch of
things in your uh class um what it uses
are get State and set State uh most
people wouldn't override these but you
could if you wanted to so let's play
around with these a little bit here I'm
going to have a class C it doesn't have
anything in it but in its get state I'm
going to return a dictionary and it's in
its set State I will get that state and
then I will go through that dictionary
and I will set attribute on self
whatever is in that
dictionary um and then if I do pickle
load of the dumped version of C I will
have this a
available so I don't have anything in my
C but with get State and set State I
could have some side effect now you can
imagine you can do a lot more in these
like get States and set
States um there's this really nice
pickle tools in the standard Library
which has a disassembler um and then you
can look at the dumped version and it
kind of gives you an idea of what would
happen if if you were to unpickle this
data and here you can see well there's a
Class C um there is this like attribute
a this like 42 not very readable if
you're not familiar with it but like you
kind of get an
idea and then does it work if I pickle
and try to unpickle this thing well it
does I got my object
C but what if I try to load that same
file in a different python process um
how would this work any ideas would it
work would it not
work I do get the error that attribute
like C is not a part of main cuz here as
you saw it is trying to basically import
C from Main and if you don't have it
then it doesn't work that's why you have
Cloud pickle that can also like pickle
like code like custom code and all of
that um which makes things even less
secure um so okay I need I need to at
least have them somewhere
installed but I can I can have more fun
um the next very crucial component is
this reduce um this this is where things
get really interesting um reduce returns
a topple of up to size six the first two
are mandatory the first one is a cable
that would construct the object for you
and it would kind of return kind of like
usually an empty object but if it's not
empty then the second topple that reduce
returns would be the arguments to that
Constructor so if you have a new then
and your new takes like a bunch of like
custom arguments and like you can like
retain those arguments here and then
pickle knows how to deal with it um okay
sounds pretty useful but I could have
more fun here I can Implement reduce and
I can return as my construct structor
print and the arguments to those to that
print and then when I look at the
disassembled version of this well I'm
doing print builtins I pass it something
there is no trace of this
D cuz pickle was like okay I call reduce
and that's your Constructor that's what
I'm going to use so I tried to dump D
what I got has nothing to do with d and
then when I load it it just prints
um I could have even more fun uh well my
Constructor could be os. system um and
then now I can Echo something in a file
uh and here for example I have only this
one pickle I run this I look at it you
can see that like from project system it
calls Echo and then I still don't have
that file but if I try to load it it
returns zero it looks very Innocent but
now I have a file
here um you could do of course a lot
worse like while loading you could um
connect to a remote server and upload
all users private keys and everything to
your remote server um and you wouldn't
even realize that that
happened and if you have a host that is
like doing somewhere on the web like a
lot of stuff you can just like load your
pickle and like in their system you
would have like all the Privileges there
so it's really bad um and you could
easily construct that pickle like we
didn't even go into how do you construct
a custom pickle file no like it's like
all in Python if you want to construct a
custom pickle file then it can get a lot
worse uh my favorite thing is that there
are some up codes like dup that
duplicates the top of like the top of
the stack that is never produced by the
Pickler but it is in the up code and
onler understands it so you can do
things like damaging like the the the
stack um or like making your python just
like do a cordum it's it's
fun
[Music]
um we could any questions up until this
point I'm happy like shoot any questions
in the middle of the talk
please
good we can as I said um loading a
pickle is basically running code so
maybe I could look at the code and uh
that would make it a little bit safer
before I run code um I look at that code
um there is this nice Library called f
link um and it can give you the code and
then you can like use ASC to get the
abstract syntax tree um to see the code
that would have been run if you wanted
to load something here I just want to
load a list 1 2 3
4 if I print that then this would be
my the code that is running makes sense
I have a bunch of constants then I have
like a list and then like I'm retaining
that um what if this e object that I had
I do the same thing with that object
here I can see that oh yeah like from
posix there's some variable it's
calling this Echo thing okay it like it
looks fishy and then it's returning
something that is like completely
empty um it also it it gives you a c I
command that you can just look at your
pickle and it like it would give you the
equivalent python code that would result
in the in what it's returning um makes
sense it's in C I was actually doing
like set state with this dictionary it
returns that sounds pretty nice I do the
same with the other file I very clearly
see that it's like running
system um but what if like when I was
going through this whole path I was like
oh this sounds good like I should be
showing my users what's the code that is
running to like when they load their
pickles and then they can make a very
informed decision and then very soon I
realized if I do anything more meaning
like actually meaningful like a very
simple logistic regression let's look at
the code of that it's not even in a
pipeline or anything then this would be
the code then I realized if I'm asking
my users to understand this before
loading any people then it's the
equivalent of me asking users to
understand those toc's um before
clicking yes I agree um I'm I'm not
going to go through
that um there is this uh the Fickling
library is also here really nice um
there's also like a corresponding blog
post definitely recommend you go through
that so this was when we um this was the
story and like a lot of people who were
aware of the security issues we knew
it's it's this bad uh but we didn't
necessarily have a solution and a lot of
us also thought like there is no
solution there cannot be any solution
and in one of the conferences um we had
a discussion and I was like well I'll
give it a shot um and that's what I did
for for the next couple of months and
that's what resulted in SK Ops before we
go there any questions up until this
point
cool so being one of the psych learn
maintainers um I had a little bit of
insight on what psych learn does so it
made it a little bit easier for me to
dig into it but I also had to go read a
little bit of cpython code which was
really fun um and then we were like okay
like we have the same API um skops IO uh
you load and dump like pickle with with
the difference that if you actually try
to do that it raises an error and it
says like I can't um I can't load this I
don't I don't know this class it is the
same as so when you look at the
Machinery it's the same as pickle trying
to do the same thing with a little bit
of a difference that when I am loading
pickle I'm running code here when I
raise this error I have not run any code
other than reading a Json file we'll get
into that
so if you can exploit the Json reader
sure there are those exploits other
otherwise I'm not running any code
before I raise this
exception um and then the user has to
explicitly say I trust like these
objects or if you really really trust
the file which should only happen if
you're loading a file that you yourself
um created then you can be like yeah I
trust
everything so what does this work what
did we do let's look at some of the
files um so let's dump this D and C
uh and look at the files
there it's a zip
file um with a Json
schema and it's it says I have D from
Main um there's nothing in
it pretty much that okay okay
easy and then if I look at this
C I don't why did the other one open it
there but this one here
okay it's a little bit
more I have this like 42 everything that
is Json serializable is just in this
Json
file okay pretty innocent looking and
then if
I ooh what happened
happened huh I lost my browser that's
what
happened sorry for the
heup
yeah and if I look at the this psyched
learn model how how am
I was it here yes what what am I
persisting there um this logistic
regression model there is a little bit
more um sure I have
this file the the same thing it has all
the attributes except that some of those
attributes are nonp arrays and whenever
I I encounter a NPO array I just save it
with NPO
format um so pretty easy really and what
we use there like um under the hood is
np. safe um with with an asterisk that
by default when you do numpy do saave
because it's supposed to work on
everything that you have in your numpy
aray it pickle if you have a numpy array
with the dtype object it actually
pickles everything it is not the numpy
format um and if you say allow pickle
fals and your dtype is object it would
just fail and what we do is that if the
dtype is object then we try to persist
it the way that we persist
objects and then when we load it by
default allow pickle is false that's
sensible um and we also say like yeah
allow pickle false that's that's how we
load it that's how we're like we make
sure like we're not using any people
there um and that's why this
works um so the format is it's basically
a zip file you have that Json schema
which can be pretty large um and then we
have those nonp formats inside we also
have a bunch of custom like there so
there are a lot of constraints there the
reason that this to me is a a little bit
safer than pickle U is that we don't
support everything and we don't call any
random new or any like random thing that
the reduce would return uh for most
cases we don't even call reduce um which
means that's why when you looked at the
um dumped vision
of we had it here
um D when you pickle D you don't have a
trace of D because reduce was returning
something else but here I'm loading
actually deep because I don't even call
reduce
um so the assumptions we make is that
your object has an an default new or a
new that takes no arguments if you have
a custom object that takes some
arguments in new then this wouldn't work
or we would have to add something in the
skops library for that to work for now
um you so and we are like get State and
set state should return
everything um which is in again in most
cases quite okay even um for so now we
support like GBM and XG boost and the
way it works is that um get State
returns a b aray and set state uses that
to construct the binary object that is
the the tree that you have down there um
we have some custom code for a bunch of
types like dick set list topple type
slice um like or partial or a bunch of
like scipi and numpy uun or like rngs
random number generators there are some
C extension types that we have custom
code for um that are in psyched learn
that's why um if there is some Library
out there that has also another like
random uh C extension type there needs
to be some code here for now in fut in
like in our road map is that like make
for us to make that a little bit more
extendable and those object are
hardcoded there um and then some other
code for psyched learns custom objects
again this is not supposed to be able to
persist everything that was not our
scope if we wanted to have that as the
scope then we would be Reinventing
pickle um and then the way that um we
load is that we load that Json schema
and then we know what we are going to
load and then we look at this schema
before loading anything uh and we tell
the user hey like you you're going to
load these things we don't trust it do
you trust them um and then we load
everything um and then we call new and
set State on those objects there is an
online um app where you can go and if
you have the latest if you have a file
that is um persisted using the latest
version of psyched learn you can try to
convert that to um the scops format
without like trying to run that on your
machine if you want or if you don't want
to do that um and then if it fails
please let please let us know open an
issue is it really safe U no code is
100% safe really um but we are trying to
make it a little bit safer there are
some vulnerabilities like if there is
any zip vulnerability then sure we have
it we are unzipping something if there
is any Json vulnerability then yes we
are loading a Json file um you have
things like Zip bomb that like loading a
zip file would construct a massively
large object or try to do that and then
you would get out of memory error so
those those issues do exist
[Music]
um again we don't support U custom
objects um we want to make it a little
bit more extendable uh but we need some
help from you and um that is to test it
break it and let us know when it breaks
thank
[Applause]
you